Iran's public prosecutor says the
country has shut down its so-called
morality police but local media has
pushed back against the comments saying
the interior Ministry oversees the force
and not the Judiciary Iran has been
rocked by months of protests sparked by
the death of a young woman in police
custody she was arrested allegedly for
not wearing her hijab properly the
demonstrations now in their third month
are the biggest challenge to the regime
in decades and protesters are calling
for a three-day strike this week
foreign
[Music]
Revolution changed the course of Iran
[Music]
authorities started monitoring the
adherence of the strict dress code
wearing the hijab hair covering became
mandatory in 1983.
over the years Iran saw several forms of
morality police
but the morality police known as kashte
irshad or guyton's petrol was
established under the hard-line former
president Mahmoud ahmediat
and the former president Hassan Rouhani
clothing Norms became slightly relaxed
but Iran's current president Ibrahim
raisi wanted a strict implementation of
the dress code
in September 22 year old Gina Masa amini
died three days after being taken into
custody by the morality police in Tehran
her alleged crime was not properly
covering her head
her death sparked unprecedented protests
across the country
Iranians demanded an end to the morality
police
they also called for a change of the
strict Islamic regime
I trembled when I heard the news because
this has happened to me once or twice it
made me think of how my parents would
feel if I suffered the same fate
I'm strongly against the morality police
because it is not possible to enforce a
cultural issue with violence
after nearly two months of protests in
which hundreds of people have been
killed the Iranian regime has signaled
some flexibility
Iran's Republic and Islamic foundations
are constitutionally entrenched
but there are methods of implementing
the Constitution that can be flexible
Iran now says it is disbanding the
morality police and is also debating the
implementation of the headscarf law
we're joined Now by Sarah bazubandi
she's a fellow at the German Institute
in global and area studies Giga Sarah
welcome to DW so what do you make of the
public Prosecutor's announcement that
Iran's morality police is being
disbanded
um I don't know if this is as your
report mentioned something to preempt
the
um what is about to happen if there is a
mass protester games take place
um in the next three days or it's just
the simple slip of the tongue and he
didn't really think about what he said
and it was right on the spot on a press
conference but in either case
um I I believe that the protesters find
a struggle to find anything positive or
meaningful in response to their demands
because they have a very clear from the
beginning of the
um protest that they are asking for a
regime change they're not asking for a
removal of head scarf and asking for
abolishment of the morality police they
want fundamental political change they
want separation of state and religion
and
hijab is only one element of that
separation so I and even if that was to
happen what he mentioned the law hasn't
changed so it really still um the law is
there
um implementation might change
temporarily but it doesn't really make
um much of a difference
Sarah would you say it's a sign though
of some sort that the authorities are
willing to heed the protesters demands
no I think that there is a certain level
of anxiety amongst the political Elites
uh because as again the report mentioned
this is one of the biggest challenges
since the revolution that Elite is
facing of course there is an effort to
find some response to call the public
down but at the same time time I don't
think that
um there is at this stage this can make
much of a difference as far as the
public is concerned so and maybe the
authorities in their own way think that
they are providing some form of
um
temporary measures to just calm the
public down but fundamentally it's it is
not really a response because this is
not what the people are asking for as
simple as they are now some are
skeptical about the announcement will
the morality police come back under
another name or a uniform are we just
going to basically not see much of a
change in that sense
foreign
as long as the law is there as I
mentioned it the implementation might
change might not it might come back in a
different form it might not and let's
not forget that even
um since the beginning of the protest
where the um presence the physical
presence of the morality police has been
a little bit
um less visible
um there are plain clothes regime
elements across public spaces that are
basically doing the same job as the
morality police was doing there are
millions of videos being circulated
um across Iranian users and social media
to show how a um plain clothes regime
elements in metros in bosses Industries
in restaurants are doing exactly the
same thing harassing women for the way
that they decided to choose their outfit
in public so implementation might change
we don't know yet but as long as the
lower the regulation is there it doesn't
really make much of a difference whether
that implementation is under a different
name whether it's done by plank levels
or officials
analyst Sarah basubandi from the German
Giga Institute thank you